what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of presidential bites today i'm
going to be recreating
a special dish that obama had from ben's
chili bowl
which is the half smoked chili dog
i know that this recipe is top secret
but is there anything that you guys can
like
share with us today well you know it's
our secret recipe
and it's loaded with love that's the key
ingredient right
exactly so where did this recipe come
from is it like a family recipe
oh my goodness the recipe came from my
husband and me
wow great recipe my husband was the
original
of the recipe so hopefully i can
represent for him and obama today
thank you guys so much all right yo
so we're getting into the chili now
something that's really interesting
about this recipe is all the amazing
spices so i can only imagine
how great this is gonna taste first
things first i have
my pot getting hot while i'm gonna get
into
the flavorings so we're going to add our
garlic powder
onion beef bouillon chili powder
masa harissa which i think thickens the
sauce
we have some cayenne some paprika
turmeric cumin and red curry powder
lots of spice so i'm just going to whisk
this up into a bowl and i'm going to
slowly pour in some water
so this is pretty much the base of the
chili it's going to be what makes the
chili super banging
and then i'm going to move back over to
the pot
we're going to add our beef into this
pot
and then we're just going to like break
it up this recipe is very interesting to
me
because the water goes straight in with
the beef which
i heard that this is what makes the
consistency of the chili like nice and
loose
not too thick so i'm just gonna break
this down
i'm gonna add some water into this
i'm gonna let this cook out so i'm gonna
grab the lid and i'm gonna put it on top
and i'm gonna make sure this is really
hot
before i add all of my flavorings my
tomato paste and
bay leaf okay so now we have
the ground beef and the water at a boil
i'm just gonna give it a mix and then at
this point
is when we're gonna add our chili
paste slush mix
straight in there straight like that
next i'm gonna give it a mix one more
time
then i'm gonna add our tomato paste
which is gonna give it that nice
sweetness and then i'm gonna add our bay
leaves
and then the lid is gonna go back on and
we're gonna cook this for about an hour
so we're going to prep the links and
we're also going to prep to vote
make sure you guys get out there and go
vote if you're not registered
do so now and by the time you come back
the chili will be ready
so now that this chili smells amazing in
here
we are going to take our hot links and
we're going to broil them
you guys can grill them or boil them but
you want to make sure you're going for
that nice smoky and snappy texture
when you bite down into your chili dog
okay guys
these dogs look amazing they're charred
and they're crispy
like i like i'm gonna go ahead and give
this a taste right before
we plate this up
tastes amazing so the way obesity
ordered this was
american mustard white onions so i'm
gonna do just that i'm just gonna add a
little bit of
actually a lot of it because i like
mustard and
i'm gonna add raw onions
right on top beautiful
i'm gonna load this up with the chili
can i do that i hope i can do that i'm
gonna do it so i'm just gonna go chili
right on top
and there we have it the presidential ob
dog smells popping it smells amazing
we're about to get into it thank god i'm
wearing an apron because i got a white
tea on
i'm just going to go for it
so i can taste all the spices coming
through the mustard on there is amazing
the white onions are giving it that nice
freshness that nice texture the chili
is really worth at though all the spices
the way it's cooked down at first i said
earlier i was like yo it's gonna be like
really weird without like browning it
but
with all that water it really made for
like a nice smooth consistency and
texture
i think this is such a presidential dog
this is banging
i see why obama ordered this shout out
to ben's chili bowl if you guys ever
make it around to dc make sure you guys
tap in with them but one thing you guys
have to do is make sure you guys tap in
get registered to vote i'm about to do
so
and fulfill my civic duties as an
american
while eating this american chili dog the
recipe for this chili dog is going to be
down below in the
deep peace out go vote do the right
thing eat a chili dog
[Music]
you